similar to dogs pigs are highly
susceptible to training due to their
social temperament but little is known
about how pigs communicate with humans
in a new study researchers at Atlas
LaRon University in Budapest looked at
how highly socialized young pigs and
puppies spontaneously interact with
humans in essence they wanted to compare
the natural inclination for
companionship and pet pigs in this test
the experimenter gave the four month old
pig and the four month old dog food
every two minutes when food was
distributed both the pig and the dog
looked at the trial runners face however
when the food was withdrawn from the
experiment only the dog continued to
look at the experimenters face the pig
decided to do other things in another
test experimenters would point to a bowl
of food and see how the untrained
animals responded to their gesture the
untrained puppy naturally followed the
pointing of the experimenter but the
untrained Pig went to the same bowl
regardless of where the experimenter was
gesture the results of these tests speak
beyond the findings that dogs are
naturally more responsive pets than pigs
since both animals are incredibly
intelligent the behaviors may say more
about their evolutionary history with
humans dogs have been domesticated for
more than 15,000 years while pigs have
been domesticated for less than 10,000
historically dogs have been used to work
with humans while pigs have been used
mainly for meat production these stark
historical differences affect the way
that pigs and dogs respond to humans
from a young age pet pigs have become
popular in the last few decades
especially with the appeal of small
breed pigs but often owners are mislead
and end up with pigs that grow to be
much bigger than expected
experts advised potential owners to be
fully informed about the responsibility
and risks associated with pets
[Music]